le chef libéral entouré d'enfants
une opération charme bien planifier le
cadre parfait pour reprendre la bataille
des votes de la classe moyenne
un gouvernement libéral va vous aider
dans vos efforts de conciliation famille
travail cette fois justin trudeau promet
de faciliter la vie des parents coincés
dans des contraintes de temps pris entre
les bouchons de circulation et l'école
ou la garderie dans un premier temps il
veut que les travailleurs régis par le
code canadien du travail puisse demander
des horaires plus flexibles et qu'ils
aient la possibilité d'accomplir leurs
tâches de la maison la mise en oeuvre
très négocier avec les provinces
dans un pays comme la grande bretagne
par exemple 80% des demandes des
employés pour ajuster leurs horaires de
travail ont été acceptées par les
employeurs c'est une question
d'améliorer la productivité c'est une
question de respect le chef
néo-démocrate lui courtisent plutôt les
jeunes familles avec la promesse d'un
service de garde à 15 dollars par jour
pour un million d'enfants
il s'est empressé de mots quitte son
adversaire politique
vous pouvez demander des heurts plus
flexible mais votre employeur peut
toujours dire non ironise thomas mulcair
mais la campagne de séduction des
familles ne s'arrête pas là les libéraux
propose aussi d'étendre le congé
parental sur 18 mois au lieu de douze
une mesure belle sur papier mais qui
dans les faits ne sera pas accessible à
tous sur cette professeure là après
henry si ça permet seulement aux
familles de prendre 18 mois tout en
recevant les mêmes bénéfices que ce qui
recevait plus ou moins une sur une
période de 12 mois
on peut s'imaginer que les familles qui
ont des revenus plus bas ne seront pas
capables de bénéficier de cette
politique là coût de cette dernière
mesure 125 millions de dollars par année
les libéraux estiment qu environ un
million de canadiens pourraient en
bénéficier mais elle ne s'appliquera pas
au québec qui s'est dotée de son propre
régime d'assurance parentale ici julie
se fera une radio canada québec